so
can we can we talk about myth and
religion a little bit
yes i mean can we start at the beginning
which is like
myths how are they born
there's this collective intelligence
amongst us human beings and we seem to
create these
beautiful ideas that captivate the minds
of millions
how is such a myth born great question
okay so that brings us to terminology
again
in um in my field we
we definitely i think try not to
distinguish between religion
i this is gonna be controversial i think
between religion and myth
because we call other cultures
religions myths right and then we call
our
myths religions and i guess myth has a
bad connotation to it that it's not
real yeah now what's interesting is that
um people like plato who lived thousands
of years ago 2
500 about um basically made this
distinction himself
within his own culture which was greek
right
so plato's a very famous greek
philosopher
and he would say things like this he
would say that um
he would make a distinction between the
reality
of the one god or the one he would call
it
he didn't call use the word god but he's
referencing a divinity of
okay and he believes in the soul okay
so but he would also say that the gods
and goddesses of the greeks are just
myths
so even he would make that distinction
again you know
he would say the population is not too
bright so they believe in these gods and
goddesses
but he himself is talking to his
students and he's basically talking
about
forms you know so you know there that
live and
seem to live in these other dimensions
like this table let's go back to this
table that we're talking
um around right now he would say that
this table is the instantiation of the
form
table and that there is this table that
actually exists somewhere
it's where this place where numbers
exist like the number two
okay so there we use the number two
mathematically therefore it exists
but have you ever seen a real one have
you ever seen the real two
no no okay so but where does it exist so
he says that tables
so he was also talking about things that
you know
he says are real making a distinction
between
the people and and by the way he got
this from socrates is
his um mentor who was killed by athens
because
he would say such things people don't
like to be told that they
what they believe in is not real right
yeah by the way his
idea of forms is just he's just making
me realize how like incredible was that
somebody like that was able to come up
with that i mean that idea became a myth
that
the idea of forms right that permeated
uh
probably the most influential set of
ideas in
in the history of philosophy in the
history of ideas
yes yeah i mean plato we know him for a
reason right
yeah so let's say that we're not
uh it's a gray area between religious
and myths and maybe not even
it is gray yeah uh so what
how's that idea with like little plato
start and
permeate through all of society oh how
does it happen okay so there are
different ways that religions
work um so a lot of people would call
the ufo
narrative today like uh and this is what
i talk about in my book like a myth
right the ufo myth but a lot of people
believe in it okay
so how do these things work well what i
did was i took
um there's a ann taves at
um uc santa barbara she's a pretty
well-known academic
who studies religion and she is this
building block
definition of religion like it builds
okay and so she says there are
there's there are no religious
experiences or
mythic experiences there are experiences
and then they get interpreted as
religious
or mythic okay and so i
i use that with the ufo narrative
so i take um and i compare it to the
religious narrative so
basically what happens um what happens
is this
is that a person generally has a very uh
intense experience
um it could be with something that they
see in the sky a being
you know that they see um you know like
moses in the burning bush or something
like that
they tell other people okay and those
other people believe them because
they say that guy let's take you okay
alex
okay so you're playing you know some of
your music
jimi hendrix shows up out of the blue so
jimi hendrix who's
who does electric church stuff right the
electric church
movement so he shows up i was uh sorry
for a small attention i was
i'm not aware of i apologize if i should
be
i'm just know how to play all of the
songs
uh electric church is this
oh yeah yeah it's jimmy hendrix's thing
yeah
that was like a philosophy of his or
what yes yes so he thought he was
it was like a mission for him like a
like he was a missionary
and he was like doing the electric
church it was through his mission
of music that he was actually impacting
people spiritually
and i think you have to agree that his
music is really spiritual yeah
wow that's so cool to know that there's
like a philosophy there yeah i wonder if
he's ever written anything
he's spoken about it many times
interesting yeah you too i actually do
some
some research here wow that adds another
level of depth that's awesome
okay so okay so say lex is playing
yeah 100 one of his song songs he shows
up what's your favorite song by the way
oh that's a hard one i like castles in
the sand it's a sad one but
yeah i like it so i'm playing something
yes
i show up and also boom just like elvis
does for people
hendrix shows up all right and then
you're amazed and then he tells you
something
that's very very significant and he says
you need to tell other people this okay
so then like okay i go on social media
yes
and you start and because people believe
you and because you
are a person of um you know credibility
people believe you and so all of a
sudden a movement starts okay
and it's the hendrix movement it's
hendrix ii or something like that you
know we call it something
uh the next iteration of hendrix right
hendrix lives
but he lives is this vibration and only
lex can like you know
can can manifest this vibration okay so
like
this is this is how religion starts you
know excuse your audience who are
religious i'm actually practicing
catholics so
um this is how religion starts they
start with first off a contact
experience
i'm not i mean not all of them but a
good portion of them
um peop some person has an experience
that's transcendent
sacred to them and they go and they tell
other people and then those people tell
other people and then something gets
written about it
okay and then it becomes because it's a
charismatic movement
people become affected by it and if if
too many people are affected by it
um an institution steps in and tries to
control the narrative
so this is what you'd call the beginning
of a religion
or a myth a very powerful myth and so
it's almost like
a star right a star is born okay yeah
when you say institution do you mean
some other organization that's already
powerful
doesn't want to become uh overpowered by
this new movement
yes absolutely is this usually
governments it's usually yeah
so i have a couple of examples so i use
the example of the christian church
in my book because i'm most familiar
with the history of christianity and you
know
christianity you know was started by
this jewish man
and it was a movement that you know he
was a very powerful charismatic person
other people believed in him and then
his followers talked about him
and then other then you know usually
early christians before the
300s were generally people who were
disenfranchised because he had a pretty
radical idea that you know
humans should have dignity and this was
pretty radical during that time so women
who didn't have dignity and you know
slaves who didn't have dignity at the
time
um converted christianity in droves
and so what happened was that all of a
sudden it became
this belief system that was undercurrent
and then
constantine who was an elite
had an experience and made christianity
a state religion
and by that time there were different
forms of christianity
probably hundreds of them well most
likely and
constantine and the people who were
powerful with him decided that their
idea
this is the council of nicaea now
decided that there was
one form and they called it universal
the one form
of christianity and this should be it
and so they
they kind of took out all the other
denominations of christianity and
different forms of it
so you can see that a very very powerful
set of beliefs
put a culture on fire right
and so how did they they had to deal
with that fire somehow
and so they narrativized it they decided
how do we interpret this and they
interpreted it
as they wished but that wasn't the only
interpretation of christianity
i have another example i'm in a catholic
church
a lot of times and i'm going to use the
example of uh faustina
she's um she's a nun and she's polish
and um i think it was in the early 20th
century if not the 1800s
that she had a very powerful uh
many experiences actually of of jesus
and she
saw jesus with rays coming out of his
his
heart and basically she called this his
divine mercy
and it became a devotion in poland and
it spread
the catholic church was not not into
this at all okay
and so they did everything they could to
try to suppress
faustina's influence which was growing
and growing
and growing and growing okay and so they
were very successful in trying to keep
her quiet
and she died okay years later john paul
ii
polish sainted her and
created the divine mercy devotion which
is worldwide now
and millions and millions of people but
you do you see how they
they you know completely control it so
fascinating that it uh
that it just starts with a single so
like you said contact experience yeah
experience is the key word and
is your sense that those experiences
are legitimate so it's not
yes for them it's artificially
constructed yeah i think for the most
part there are legitimate experiences
that people have
why would someone want to put themselves
through what they go through like why
would jesus want to get crucified i mean
that's a pretty nasty way to
die um you know why would faustina bring
this upon herself
um the people that i meet who've said
that they've seen ufos that most of them
don't want to be known
because of the ridicule that goes along
with it so i honestly think that
you know there are people who are maybe
not stable and
would like the attention but for the
most part normal people don't want this
attention
you